so I would tell people that in my heart
I want to stop with these military
interventions in my heart I don't want
to send our men and servicewomen to lose
their lives and I don't want them to be
responsible for what ultimately our
thousands of innocent people being
killed in these countries so Hillary
Clinton dots the i's and crosses the t's
on all of the all of the names and
everything associated with this but as a
result of that we have the foreign
policy that we have right now that I
have to tell you I think is horrible
horrible and that's how I would answer
it tonight I would be mad I would be
angry I would be angry that people would
be calling me out on the names of
geographic locations names of foreign
leaders when the underlying policy has
thousands of people dying and that is
unacceptable this is the Gary Johnson
that you would have seen in the debates
it angers me to no end because what I'm
saying I think echo is what most people
think the what we do is ridiculous what
we do is absorb you have there's more
support for you guys to be included in
the debate then there are people who
would vote for you
why do you think that there's so much
because that has to do everything to do
everything with the fact that that both
of them are vilified both of them are
unpopular 60% of
view them negatively I think it's pretty
clear that we don't have a qualitative
problem with the ticket we have only a
quantitative problem which is getting
known by 15% of the might written
instead of 30% and if we go to a 50%
recognition a little bit of 25% ballot
preference because Gary doesn't have the
negatives that the two major party
candidates seem to have straightforward
now you guys aren't going to be in this
debate you may not be in the VP debate
so what do you guys do between now and
the third debate - well you know we tell
our story it's a matter of going around
and trying to persuade the national
media among others as well as the people
that we see every day that we offer an
alternative to the - establishment
parties and that we're fiscally
responsible and that we're socially
inclusive both of which things we proved
to our two terms each of us in office so
the difference between us and brandy and
brandy is that we've been there and done
that and nobody can argue that we didn't
change our states and we were Republican
governors in democratic states so by
definition we had to work across the
aisle to get our programs enacted and we
didn't we both moved our states and more
conservative direction is pistol nobody
can just give you them so you know hope
is not a plan we have a plan is to do
what we've already done I mean I think
this is not a really good point here you
are at Twitter and you have a direct
pipe into the people who are supporting
how are you guys using things tools like
that and what do you hear from the
people who do support you what are they
asking well I think that we because of
the tools that we do have available
Twitter being right at the top of the
list that we are able to communicate and
thank you
so this really is a year of social media
it's not a year where blog paid for
advertising in the last week that
campaign is going to swing the election
because people will tune that out once
you get past 1215 gross rating points
per week so every man woman dog and cat
comes through the app you know 17 times
and I think decisions get made virally
social media and across the fence we
have we have understood today that
Hillary is spending 18 million dollars
right now to discredit us that is more
money than we will end up probably
having in the campaign to conduct our
campaign
what do you guys it's just that it's
just it's horrible why would you even
say that we're giving people a chance to
vote or something as opposed to the
lesser of two evils that's what we are
that's what we are providing first vote
you want to waste your vote with Hillary
or Clinton or or Trump go right ahead
and waste your vote
we're not spoilers we are the first vote
last question so I guess we should drop
out is that what you're saying is that
is that your editorial here is that we
should drop out it's another way of
putting it is that this is a year when
the voters really constellation the
Stars the voters do have to think for
themselves and we think if they do think
to themselves that they'll recognize
that we're by way of middle which is
fiscally insert that have been socially
liberal which is about 60% of the people
in the United States in business terms
that's a pretty good addressable market
so it's a question of getting that story
out there we'd love to be on the stage
tonight but failing that we're very
grateful for the chance to tell our
story through this meeting last question
given the amount of money that's being
spent on both sides obviously you don't
have as much money spent if you had them
both equally the other candidates in
everything I do I absolutely believe
that if we were just given top-line
polling that we would be in the debates
thanks so much guys really appreciate it
yeah